I think we've learned a lot in the 15
years and so you know maybe that has
been the most valuable thing the biggest
impact we've had so far has been in
childhood health we created in the year
2000 this group called gobby has saved
over 10 million lives and a lot of kids
who would have been sick and not fully
developed even if they'd survived the
vaccines that have made a big difference
for them so that one's the best you know
and everything else has to be measured
by that that kind of breakthrough
success indeed it's hard to top saving
10 million lives what was the biggest
mistake well a lot of things required us
to get in and try out pilot programs and
see what would work in education you
know the structure of high schools
trying to make it so they weren't quite
so big we saw some benefits there but
that loan wasn't enough how you get
teachers more feedback about what
they're good at and how they improve
letting them be exposed to other
teachers doing things better that we've
gone through many iterations we have
some pilot sites that have done very
very well but still today the secret to
how you raise the average teacher up to
be as good as the the top 10% not yet
solved and yet so valuable and some
places where we have have that result
that we do want to figure out how to
scale it up so a lot of things take more
time than I expect how about the most
valuable lesson you learned well our
early years we thought we were so naive
we should just work on our own invest in
science not trying team up and influence
joint strategies as we got further down
the learning curve particularly in
health then we saw that we needed to
come together with the government aid
budgets and the groups in the field so
how you develop those partnerships
whether it's with the UN groups like
UNICEF and w-h-o country groups like
USAID the nonprofit groups like
or care save the children building on
our complementary strengths where we
understand our D better than than these
groups they understand the field better
than we do how you make all that come
together that kind of partnership model
it's been a huge learning curve and I do
think we're we're far better at it now
than than ever